Hey guys,
Tim Ferriss here.
I want to show you what I have in my
bag for Doug tricks and dog training.
This is a question that I've had a fair
amount and I do think there are some key
elements. So first of all,
fashion is not a priority.
So you can see I have
the rock in Venice beach,
1980s fanny pack, rollerblader
style doesn't matter. Uh,
I have tried different versions
with carabiners and whatnot.
Some of them look like chalk bags. They
have a drawstring, all a huge hassle.
So I would not use those.
This is a dog gone.
Good exclamation point, which I actually
find very good for a number of reasons.
There is a magnet,
so you can just do that and it
will close this to a draw string.
This becomes important when
food starts breaking apart.
So a couple of elements that
I want to point out here.
The first is that I have
primary pocket with dog treats.
All right, now I have a Ziploc bag
to prevent continual washing of this.
As far as the dog treats go,
you can use kibble.
You can use really cheap crap.
But as one of the trainers that I worked
with said to me, it's a crowded bar.
You got a tip of 20s. So if you're
giving them kibble, for instance,
there was a period of two
or three weeks where Bali,
my pup wasn't responding to
anything, wasn't replying to
recall, meaning, you know,
come Molly wasn't doing anything
and it's giving you this kibble.
And it worked for a while and it didn't
compute that I needed to up the ante and
go from ones to fives
to tends to twenties.
And that's when I started using
these lamb treats from origin, uh,
which are the equivalent
of 20s and immediately,
no difference in the
training within a week. Uh,
things took a complete hockey street,
a hockey stick trajectory. So, uh,
that is part one.
Now on the inside pocket,
I do like that this has multiple pockets.
This was more useful and necessary when
she was a pup, but it had one of these,
and I use this for
getting her into the car.
I use this for getting her attention. And
this is a squeaker from a squeaker toy,
so it's usually inside some
type of plush animal, but
that is an irresistible sound to most
young dogs and gets their attention
immediately. So this was used very
early on. I don't use it as much,
if at all these days. All right. Few
other things that I want to point out.
There aren't that many. I keep this
on my right side. Almost always.
Molly is very consistently on my left
side and there were some differences of
opinion among trainers as to
which side you should have it on.
I don't think by and large
it matters all that much. Uh,
what I like to do is have this side
pocket immediately available for the
clicker.
Now you'll notice that I've positioned
the clicker so that as soon as I pull it
out,
sort of like positioning a handgun,
as soon as I have this and I pull
it out, it's ready to click. Okay.
That is a reward marker.
So if I say, Molly,
come hand marker, she comes
poke, I can pick this out,
click and then give her a treat.
All right.
And there's obviously a lot more to it,
but the clicker is a
constant companion for me.
I use it for precision if we're
working on new behaviors, new skills,
and the best books for that that I found,
I've read 20 or 30.
I'm sure there are other
good ones out there,
but the most concise and I
think actionable are don't
shoot the dog by Karen
prior with the extra chapter on clicker
training and a very hard to find book
called command performance, which is
a compilation by whole dog journal.
I'm sure it's in Berkeley or
Portland or somewhere and uh,
that is effectively one behavior every
two pages and it gives you a good
overview of positive enforcement training,
opera and classical conditioning,
etc. Okay,
next we have emergency pocket.
All right. So I have a very
weak whistle. Meaning if I'm,
it's not going to work for my dog is
200 feet away or 200 yards away. Right?
I've tried to learn how to whistle with
my fingers. It's comical. It's terrible.
It's completely tragic. So until
I'm able to do that, I have the,
the emergency pocket.
Now this is to get ahold of Molly if
she just goes Gonzo into red line and
starts taking off.
There are two options and uh,
it depends really a, this is going
to be my first course of action. Um,
and this is a dog whistle.
All right?
So kind of like Mariah Carey record
sort of dog whistles. This is,
that's all that you hear. All right?
So it doesn't bother other humans.
She will hear this for sure.
Okay. So that's option number one.
And then if I really need
to pull the emergency brake,
this one is the regular old whistle.
Okay.
And I have a very particular whistle.
I'm not going to give it out cause I
don't want other people imitating it,
but I do have a particular
whistle and cadence to recall it,
Molly, right? So yours
could be like whatever.
It might be making it more
unique than just rover. But, uh,
everybody has the same whistle.
So pick up something that is your own
unique sort of code or Morse code for
recalling your dog. And, uh,
those are the items in my bag
that are most consistently used,
very versatile,
very easy to travel with.
I keep this fully stocked at all times
and just leave it by the door as is,
and I can grab the leash, grab this,
and off I go. If you enjoyed that video,
let's talk about a list. Arnold
Schwarzenegger, Jamie Foxx,
undisputed King of Big Wave Surfing.
Laird Hamilton. The list goes on and on.
What do they have in common?
They're sharing their secrets,
their morning routines, favorite books,
everything with me on my podcast,
the Tim Ferriss show, 70 million
plus downloads, iTunes, best of 2015.
Check it out.
You will not be disappointed.